we are told the pedigree chart
represents the inheritance of
colorblindness through three generations
and we see this here the standard
convention is a square is male circle is
female if it's colored in that means
that they exhibit the trait in this case
it's colorblindness so bill exhibits
colorblindness his phenotype is
colorblind while bonny does not exhibit
colorblindness colorblindness is an
x-linked recessive trait if Barbara is
expecting another child so this is
Barbara right here what is the
probability that it will be colorblind
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out on your own alright now
let's work through this together so
they're asking us about their next child
here what is the probability that it is
going to be colorblind and to help us
with that we can try to figure out the
genotypes of Tom and Barbara so tom is
pretty straightforward he is male we
know that because there's a square there
so X has an X chromosome and he has a Y
chromosome and colorblindness is an
x-linked recessive trait and so let me
just make clear what's going on so I'll
do lowercase C for colorblind color
blind and I could do a capital C for the
dominant trait which is not colorblind
but since they look so similar I'll just
use a plus for not colorblind not color
not colorblind and so Tom his phenotype
he is colorblind and so and he only has
one X chromosome where the colorblind
what the color Bryant trait is linked to
and so that must have the recessive
allele right over there
so this is Tom's genotype but what about
Barbara well we know Barbara is going to
have two x chromosomes because Barbara
is female and we know that both of them
can't be lowercase C because then
Barbara would exhibit colorblindness but
how can we figure out her actual
genotype well we could look at her
parents so bill over here is going to
have the same genotype as tom at least
with respect to colorblindness he is
male so he has an X chromosome and a Y
chromosome and because he exhibits
colorblindness that X chromosome must
have the recessive colorblind
allele associated with it now Bonnie we
do not know she will be ex ex will have
two x-chromosomes
like Barbara we know that both of these
can't have the recessive allele because
then Bonnie would be filled in she would
exhibit colorblindness but we don't know
whether she is a carrier or whether she
isn't but let's just think about where
Barbara got her chromosomes from one of
her X chromosomes comes from her father
and the other one comes from her mother
so if she got this X chromosome from her
father her father only has one x
chromosome to give the one that has the
colorblind allele so if this is from her
father it must have the colorblind
allele here and we know that the one
from her mother is does not have the
colorblind allele because if it was like
this then Barbara would be colorblind
and she isn't so we know that this must
be a plus here it is the dominant non
colorblind allele and so now we know
both of their genotypes and we can use
those to then figure out the possible
outcomes for their offspring so for
example Tom can contribute a X
chromosome that has a colorblind allele
or a Y chromosome and Barbara right over
here can contribute an X chromosome that
has a colorblind allele or an X
chromosome that has the non colorblind
allele Barbara is a carrier and so let
me just draw a little punnett square
here and so we have four possible
outcomes for their children and they're
all equally likely so you can get the X
chromosome from Barbara that has the
colorblind allele and the X chromosome
from Tom that has the colorblind allele
you could have the X chromosome from
Barbara with a colorblind allele and the
Y chromosome from Tom you could have the
non colorblind x chromosome Oly or the X
chromosome that does not have the
colorblind allele on it and get the
colorblind X chromosome from Tom
or you could have the non colorblind X
chromosome and the Y chromosome from the
father so there's four equal scenarios
and so in how many of these scenarios is
the offspring colorblind well here we
have a colorblind female she has two of
the recessive alleles so that female
will be will be colorblind this is a
female carrier but they will not show
the phenotype of being colorblind this
over here is a colorblind male has only
one X chromosome and it has the color
rind the colorblind allele on it and
this is a non colorblind male so out of
four equal outcomes two of them have the
offspring being colorblind so two out of
four that would be a 50% probability
that the offspring will be colorblind